This video is brought to you by dragon city,
Jack Jared here and today,
we're talking about the smart and stylist J RPG that lets you simultaneously
date your high school teacher, your middle school, age, step stepsister,
and an alcoholic lowest lane, persona five. For those of you,
who've never played persona five.
We recommend pausing this video and playing through the 120 hour campaign.
But if you don't have that much time, we'll summarize it for you.
The persona series is basically what you get.
If a group of otaku made a Pokemon clone set in the world of inside out,
he spent half the game and a high school, social management simulator,
and the other half is a superhero gentlemen,
fif that enters people's cognitions in order to catch them all, I'll be it.
Instead of Peaky, choose your nabbing, mythological monsters, gods heroes,
historical figures, and characters or literature,
including whatever the hell this is going by. The code name joker.
You slowly assemble a crew called the Phantom thieves of hearts to heist the
inner most desires from the most powerful and corrupt adults in society.
You sons of, what's the job.
So let's look at whether the aspects of persona,
which people praise so often are actually deep or dumb quarters ahead for the
original game, but not for the expanded version persona fibroid,
which won't be stateside until the end of March. Before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to dragon city,
a mobile RPG available on iOS and Android.
Dragon city is like a hero collector, but instead of heroes,
you collect dragons,
generate gold to buy food and level up your dragons for battle.
There are hundreds of very cute and very ferocious dragons hidden in dragon city
for you to collect. I recently found the binge dragon, my personal favorite,
the movie fanatic dragon, and a serial killer dragon.
There's even a poo dragon.
You can also breed different species to complete your collection.
I bred my binge dragon with my movie fanatic dragon,
and they had a neon dragon collect as many dragons as you can and use them in
battle. But more on that later,
you can download the game for free using the link in the description.
And now back to the show part one union psychology,
Carl Yoon was the founder of analytical psychology just as his colleagues,
Sigmund Freud invented an entire vocabulary for psychoanalysis human coin terms
like archetype shadow persona and the collective unconscious and the series
cites its union influences explicitly and persona for golden,
you can unlock new episodes of Mr. EDA gal was TV classroom,
which are straight up lectures about Jungian psychology,
but the primary place you encounter these union terms is during the combat
sections. When our regular high schoolers enter the metaverse,
they transform into personas that are dramatizations of the union concept much
in the same way as joy and anger in inside out our drama desertions of emotions.
Really the whole world of persona is a dramatization of Young's ideas about the
human psyche.
Take the metaverse a world created by human cognition that the Phantom thieves
are capable of entering the metaverse is representative of all psychological
activity, collective and individual conscious and unconscious.
Some parts called palaces represent an individual's mental activity,
specifically their distorted perspective of a place in the real world.
Take the girls volleyball, coach comma Shita.
He's got such a high opinion of his status at Shujin Academy that he envisions
it as a castle ruled by him as its King.
Other parts such as momentos are how society as a whole sees the world around
it. And given the deep cynicism of the day, it's not a pleasant place.
This shared psychic space society along with the sea of souls,
from which all shadows and personas our drama dissertations have a union concept
called the collective unconscious it's those parts of the mind that we inherited
from our most remote ancestors like fight or flight,
but it also includes what you described as preexistent forms, the archetypes,
which give definite form to certain psychic contents of the innumerable
archetypes within the collective unconscious. You can consider for I'm ordeal,
the most basic and universal images among which are the persona and the shadow
personas are social masks that the ego chooses to wear you and himself described
them as designed on the one hand to make a definite impression upon others.
And on the other to conceal the true nature of the individual in Latin persona
refers to the masks worn by actors and in the game,
whenever they enter the metaverse,
the Phantom quite literally where their personas as masks per young,
the thieves personas are how they want society to see them and how they want to
see themselves take on who is apprehensive about her beauty,
because it draws unwanted attention. When her persona awakens, it says Carmen,
from the famous opera,
a fierce femme fatale who uses her pension for seduction to deadlift fact
effectively this transforms ons appearance liability into a strength.
Another union is shadow or the psychological aspects,
which the conscious self is unaware of and would rather not acknowledge in the
game. Shadows serve as the enemies, most are generic,
but the bosses are shadows specific to certain characters,
but the game designers didn't just look too young for their world-building.
His ideas are equally represented in the game, play mechanics as well.
The way shadows and personas are grouped reflects yeoman's concept of archetypes
per EWM. The term archetype is often misunderstood as meaning certain definite
mythological images are motifs,
but the archetype is a tendency to form representations of a motif
representations that can vary a great deal in detail without losing their basic
pattern. So the personas aren't themselves, well,
part of the collective unconscious that everyone inherits,
no one is born with the idea of Odin in their head,
but they do have part of their mental space sequestered off for the idea of
Senex, the generic wise old man. And this idea is given form through characters,
such as Odin, Paul and [inaudible],
who are all grouped together in the game organization to capture a shadow.
Joker must find some point of commonality with it. That is,
he must recognize it as being part of himself.
Similarly confronting and recognizing one's own shadows is a distinctive asset
[inaudible] process of individuation.
Once he's moved it from the dark parts of his psyche into the light of
consciousness, joker can then equip the shadow as a persona,
but there's another game game play use for personas that better exemplifies the
union concept as joker converses with important people called confidence,
his bond with them strengthens each of these has a particular archetype that
most closely exemplifies their personality by equipping a persona belonging to
the same archetype before conversing with a confidant joker forges his
friendship with them faster.
Since they're recognizing something of themselves in him.
This is people of Young's idea that we were different personas for different
people,
choosing to share one side of ourselves with friends and other with family and
another, with coworkers even more youngian is the Phantom thieves,
entire modus operandi. They enter into their marks, psyche and steal,
whatever it is, the individual treasures.
So much that it's twisted their desires and distorted their perception of
reality and always end up confronting the Target's shadow.
After this treasure is stolen and the shadow defeated the individual undergoes a
dramatic change of personality.
This can be seen as a kin to psychotherapy despite stylizing themselves as
thieves.
Their goal is to affect psychological and moral improvement in the subject,
albeit less talking on a couch to defeat inner demons and more slashing them
with samurai swords, given all this,
the consonance between the world-building story and the game play mechanics all
around this one, unifying motif.
And we've absolutely got to give personas use of Jungian and psychology,
a certified deep part, two esoteric taro.
The game continues its union motifs with the use of taro to Oregon.
The nice elements such as shadows, personas, and confidence.
According to the archetypes found in the cards you and himself acknowledged the
taro as containing compassion, selling archetypical imagery, he wrote,
it also seems to as if the set of pictures in the taro cards were distantly
descended from the archetypes of transformation.
Taro began back in the 15th century as a deck for playing card games.
In addition to the traditional four suits, AKA the minor Arcana,
it included 22 Trump cards, the major Arcana.
It wasn't until the late 18th century that it began to be used for hope purposes
of which you're probably most familiar with cartoon scene or defining the future
by drawing cards.
But apart from fortune telling the Terrell was also corporated into a cult
schools of thought with each partaking on multitudes of me,
such as the major Arconic corresponding to one of the 22 letters of the Hebrew
alphabet and 22 paths of the Kabbalah tree of life,
or the four suits of the minor Arcana corresponding to the four classical
elements and the four letters of the Tetra.
Gramaton the use of the taro as a set of symbols,
became known as esoteric taro to distinguish it from its primary purpose as
playing cards.
The order of the major Arcana also tells us story known as the fool's journey
that is seen as both the story of each individual soul and the history of the
universe as a whole persona fives.
Most successful well application of esoteric taro is in structuring its
confidence system around the fool's journey.
Joker's own journey begins when he meets Igor,
the confidant associated with Arcana zero Lamott,
AKA the fool in esoteric taro.
The fool is at the first on a path towards self-realization with that path,
taking him through these subsequent cards of the major Arcana.
This is reflected in Joker's need to maximize his rank with all of his
confidence.
Each of whom is explicitly linked to one of the major Arcana and whose own side
story teaches joker, the lessons of their associated card.
It's not enough for him to simply beat the final boss like the fool he has to
achieve enlightenment in the way prescribed by esoteric taro in order to unlock
the game's true ending,
which are kind of the confidence belonged to often reflects the role they play
in the narrative.
Occasionally the game makes a particularly appropriate connection regarding what
our Connor a character belongs to and which persona they manifest.
MCOs are Connor is Lopez traditionally associated with the legendary Pope. Joan,
the very same as Mercado's initial persona Yohanna,
but more often the game makes a surface level association between the characters
are Connor and their personality ons.
Arcana is Le Amaru the lovers primarily because she is the first love interest
available in the game and the object of desire to multiple male characters,
Futaba of our meat, literally hermits herself away in her room.
[inaudible] of the, of fourtune is herself a tarot reading,
fortune teller and Tate to Kimmy's work in the medical field,
places her in proximity to death, hers being the card with no name,
AKA Lamotte.
This last one reveals how Alice his understanding of esoteric taro can be a bit
shallow is the 13th. Arcana is associated not with literal death,
but is rather symbolic of endings and change. In some cases,
the surface level connections come at the cost of a deeper one powers.
Final persona [inaudible] of the emperor Sakana is specifically called the queen
of heaven in the Bible.
This naturally compares her with Mary whom the Catholics affirm as the Regina
Chaley, the queen of heaven. However, Arthur, Edward Waite,
who co-created the most famous esoteric taro deck contrast the Empress with Mary
as queen of heaven saying the emphasis is associated with Mary only as refugee
impeccably. Horam the refuge of sinners and an earthly garden of Eden.
According to him, the emperor is very specifically not a heavenly figure.
The game gets it backwards. This is hardly nitpicking. Esoteric.
Tarot is interesting specifically because its imagery and structure invite
systemization with diverse schools of thoughts,
like the Jewish Kabbalah and the Catholic Corpus doctrine in getting the
meanings mixed up persona five,
doesn't quite justify structuring its systems around the taro.
The game is obviously interested in taro for its esoteric associations as well
as its union ones,
but fails to engage with the esotericism in any real meaningful ways.
The fact that the game follows the taro of Marsay, an older deck,
more associated with card games rather than the rider Waite deck,
which was specifically constructed to convey esoteric symbolism,
certainly evidences this while the fool's journey of the confidant system and
one or two of the characters associated Arcana are somewhat deep for the most
part persona five's use of taro is kind of dumb part three
ethical systems and moral realism, but.
Persona five is also structured to make a moral argument.
The story is built around.
Heisting a few major palaces parts of the metaverse that have been warped by the
distorted perception of a sinful individual because the Phantom thieves suck at
sneaking all of their heist culminate in a climactic boss,
battle against the palaces owner or lease their shadow.
These big bads are based on the seven deadly sins with each one of the palaces
explicitly named after one of the vices.
Number one comma Shita like many dudes who coach high school girls athletics is
pervy. His palace is the castle of lust inside it.
His shadow looks like as modus who according to theologian,
Peter bins filled is the Prince of hell associated with lust to modern.
Rami is an artist that uses other people's works to promote his own fame.
So his palace is the museum of vanity.
Three kind of Shiro is a corpulent crime boss who hungers for more and more
money from those he IX stores that may sound like greed,
but his palace is the bank of gluttony,
a theme reinforced not only by his road tenacity,
but by the BLC bulb like appearance of his shadow.
That being the demon bins filled connected to gluttony for Futaba,
his anger at herself for apparently causing her mother's death results in her
palace.
Being the pyramid of wrath five Okumura is a businessman who envisions his
employees as robots existing only to labor for him,
his palace being the spaceship of grief. He isn't interested in money solely,
but wealth in all its various expressions. I E Mamon.
So it's appropriate that the same demon is also the name of his shadow. Again,
following bins fields list six niyama is a prosecutor who is so envious
of her colleagues when records that she's willing to do anything to get a
conviction. Her palace is the casino of envy for the house always wins.
And her shadow per bins filled is Leviathan seven Cheeto is a politician
who,
when he tried to force himself on a woman and joker saved her head joker charged
with assault is expressed AME as prime minister is a screw over the unwashed
masses while profiting his chosen few, you know, a typical politician.
His palace is the cruiser of pride.
Traditionally that deadly is sent eight humanity as a whole is responsible for
such intellectual and moral laziness that they collectively have a distorted
perception of reality leading to the public palace known as mementos,
AKA the prison of slough. And no, we didn't forget how to count.
The seven deadly sins have as their antecedent.
The monk Evagrius pontic says eight evil thoughts until Pope Gregory.
The first subsumed Vainglory under pride, the ordering.
Of the villains occurrences conforms roughly to the.
Severity of the sins per traditional Catholic understanding.
This has seen most vividly in Dante Purgatorio. Dante is ordering was lust,
gluttony, avarice, slaw wrap, and be fried.
This is essentially the same as the order of the palaces and persona with one
important difference.
Persona moves sloths to the final slot suggesting that slot is
properly the deadliest sin.
In addition to the inherent evil of their signature sin,
the villains are also ordered with respect to their sphere of influence with
greater influence, allowing for a greater severity to their transgressions.
Whereas comma sheet, his influence is limited only to Shujin Academy.
Modern Rami has influenced over the entire art community can have Shiro over a
wide swath of the criminal underworld and Okamura and Shito on a national stage
as captains of business and politics. Respectively,
the final boss is Yalda beyo,
a Gnostic name for the creator of the world because it wouldn't be a proper J
RPG. If you didn't kill God at the end and being God,
his influence extends over the whole of humanity.
The name Yalda beyo comes from the Apocrypha and of John.
Now the arc-on who is weak has three names. The first is yelled Aveo.
The second is sock floss and the third is SEM mil.
This connects Yalda beyo with the penultimate boss Shito whose shadow is mil and
joker himself as sock Kloss means fool a reference back to joker being on the
fool's journey. Now the narrative progresses in one other interesting way.
The villains are ordered roughly according to which system of ethics they're
supposed authority derives from comma,
cheetah and Mata Rami are both adults in positions of authority,
preying on high schoolers, comma, Ashita,
by hitting on literal and Mata Rami by stealing his students' artwork,
neither his actions aligned with any ethical theory,
both simply presumed that age gives them natural authority.
This is pretty much the first ethical framework.
Any individual operates under to listen to those older than us can a Shiro
self-loathing at his own perceived weakness,
leads him to operate under the theory that might makes right and to build a
criminal enterprise to compensate.
All of these are what psychologists Lawrence Kohlberg in his stages of moral
development categorized as pre-conventional such moral attitudes are marked by
their deference to superior power or prestige as opposed to principled moral
reasoning. Alternatively, as a prosecutor side,
ne Jima occupies Kohlberg's fourth stage of moral development,
a conventional category in which the law itself is the foundation for morality,
whether or not the law is actually just Szeto and Yalda bailed represent
Kohlberg's post-conventional stages of moral development as prime minister
shadow's authority derives from the consent of the governed.
This is Kohlberg's fifth stage in which laws are malleable based on the will of
the masses. Kohlberg's sixth stage is that of universal ethical principles,
right? And wrong are the same for all people at all places at all times,
regardless of man-made laws,
one permutation of a universal ethical principle is divine command theory.
The idea that the foundation of morality is whatever God says is right or wrong
as a stand in for God.
Ya'll debate is representative of this type of moral reasoning in fighting all
of these foes.
The Phantom thieves are not merely opposing the deadly sins themselves,
but also the various ethical frameworks to which society has subscribed.
And we think this is why the structure of the game impute slop as the deadliest
sin of all humanity Slav has made it intellectually and morally lazy.
Humanity has abdicated the hard work of moral decision making to these various
ethical systems and even harder work of actually being morally active members of
society to those few individuals running the various spheres of influence.
And unfortunately they've not been particularly more the themes while far from
being immoral or amoral don't neatly conform their ethical hand-wringing to any
prescribed ethical theories.
This is what differentiates them from the slothfulness of the masses under the
sway of Yalda beyo throughout all the heist cumulatively the thieves go through
an ethical process that French philosophers Jaak Derry dot described as
undecidability essentially all moral decisions come down to deciding between
taking actions based on a moral framework or rejecting those actions for any
reason,
ranging from not feeling like it to distrust for the moral frameworks at play.
For instance,
the thieves consistently reject the justifications for laws that side need Jima
blindly enforces.
And even when the rules seem to have a foundation such as shadows,
democratic mandate or yell to bail,
divine commands such wrote formula won't necessarily apply to individual
circumstances. Thus,
according to dairy dot all the moral decision-making is undecidable by
prescribed ways of thinking a decision that did not go through the ordeal of the
undecidable would not be a free decision.
It would only be the programmable application or unfolding of a calculable
process,
only exerting great moral and intellectual effort by continually undergoing
Derridean undecidability time. And again,
throughout their careers are our heroes able to avoid the deadly sin of
slaw, but while the Phantom Phoebes avoided slothfulness themselves,
by being the only ones to take on these various systems,
they become a moral crutch who everyone and else outsources their
decision-making too. So whether it's the thieves or,
or [inaudible] the end result is the same.
This is why ya'll debate remains as powerful as ever even after Shito is
defeated. At first,
this seems to be an example of the game's mechanics coming into conflict with
its narrative.
The story is saying that society itself has to overcome its moral lethargy,
but by virtue of being a game that can only come about by decisions you as the
player,
make the NPCs never make a real choice and continue to avoid confronting
undecidability and continue being slothful hiding the true ending behind
maxing out all the confidence is a smart solution to this problem.
That is to say that in the true ending,
all the NPCs who help with the final victory have gone through the same ethical
challenge as the Phantom thieves,
despite challenging such ethical frameworks by framing the decision to decide
Troy Yalda bailed as unambiguously, right?
Ultimately affirms moral realism.
Even if no one ethical system can fully articulate what makes good right and
evil wrong, good and evil are very much real. It could be Dems,
the moral nihilism of the games, foil Goro, a catchy.
This is a departure from Derrida who rejects the notion that we're ever
approaching a true ethics and claims undecidability is the whole of the matter.
But the game says it's only a step toward the truth of right and wrong.
Thankfully, the game is.
Much more clear than real life and assuring that you did the right thing mainly
by rewarding you with an anime wife who on Valentine's day.
So for balancing the complication of ethical systems with an affirmation of
moral realism and giving as extensive and examination of moral wrongdoing as
Dante persona five is as deep as the ninth circle of hell.
But tell us what you think wisecrack are being too much like fortune tellers,
reading too much into what's just not there.
Or did we successfully infiltrate your cognition and force a change of heart as
to how you feel about persona five?
Let us know in the comments below big shout out to all our awesome patrons.
Don't forget to subscribe. And before you go,
I want to give one last shout out to dragon city.
Once you have a collection of dragons,
you can take them to battle and collect gold and exp here,
you can see me using food to level up my movie, fanatic dragon.
And after some training, you should definitely be able to win some battles game.
Also offers different PVP modes,
where you can take your favorite dragons and fight in the leagues or in the
arena. There are new events every week, like match three puzzles and mazes.
So start growing your dragon collection and go to battle today,
hit the link in the description to download the game for free and as always.
Thanks for watching guys.
[Inaudible].